Ladies and Gentlemen,
welcome to the 75th annual
Miss Fairest of Them All!
(applause)
These ladies have been working real hard
and tonight, we will find
Miss Fairest of Them All.
Are you ready?
Let's get started.
(ominous music)
(footsteps)
(silence)
What happened?
You passed out.
It was very dramatic.
(accordion)
Your square was great.
You made it to the evening gown.
How long was I out?
Less than a minute.
Oh god, it's happening faster,
I...
I keep having this dream...
(ominous music)
So you did the whole routine with it broken?
Yup.
All 3 toes.
Damn, Kansas.
The more it hurt, the more I smiled.
What?
You're...
You're all dead.
You seem a little nuts, Hawaii...
Maybe you should like,
not be in this pageant right now,
and go see a doctor?
No, none of us should be in the pageant...
they're--they're gonna announce that I won,
and then--
(laughs)
Keep dreaming...
No, you don't understand!
(ominous music)
(ominous vocalizing)
Alright ladies, you know the drill.
3rd runner up, 2nd runner up,
1st runner up, winner...
and smile!
No no no no no no no...
Hope, you can't go on stage!
Shhhh.
All that's left to do is stand up there and smile!
No, you don't understand!
(ominous music)
Fantastic.
And the 3rd runner up of Miss Fairest is...
Miss Georgia!
(applause)
You almost passed out, but we held you up.
You're welcome.
(ominous buzz)
(ominous music)
And the winner is...
Miss Hawaii!
(applause and cheer)
You did it!
You won!
(ominous buzz)
(applause and cheer)
(screaming)
It was just the balloons...
(screams continue)
YOU!
(screaming)
(screaming builds)
(screams continue)
(ominous vocalizing)
(ominous music)
(feedback)
(disharmonous music)
(ominous sounds build)
(sounds die out)
(scarce piano)
Subtitles by Skylar Coland via Amara